[Music]
oh just who in the hell do you think you
are
that was awesome
he's so chewed
good what's that he says welcome to the
frickin guardians of the galaxy holy he
didn't use fricken
oh look out oh wow I tried guys
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
arms don't let me go
there are two types of things in the
universe
those are dance those who do not
I get it yes I am a dancer Cory is not
you just need to find a woman who is
pathetic
like you thanks boy do you need a hug
no no I do not oh I thought I said no
you're welcome
[Music]
the fate of the universe lies on your
shoulders now whatever you do don't push
this but cuz that will set off the bomb
immediately and we'll all be dead
now repeat back what I just said
calm it no that's the button of them
kill everyone try again
Conkel mm-hmm oh good uh-huh okay no
Showtime a-holes up
in the way
you spaceship
does anybody have any paper out there I
want to put some tape over the debt but
nobody has any tape not a single person
has paid you have an atomic bomb in your
bag if anybody's gonna have tape with
you I have to do it for you that's a
really bad sign
if I touch someone I can feel their
feelings your feel yeah yeah I guess
yeah I feel a general unselfish love for
somebody no sexual no no I don't know
hahaha see you stole everyone your
deepest darkest secret dude come on I
think you're overreacting a little
you must be so embarrassed hahahahaha
maybe technicality Amazing Grace how
sweet the sound